so as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your is your
block as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation
on this side so we'll start off with the accuracy first so uh your accuracy is actually scored from
a four so from the number four uh you're actually marked during your uh presentation of your pattern
and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus
of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll i'll just let you guys know about
the difference between the two
so with the minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say we're doing a outer block
if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a tiny bit
higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to do
an outer block in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead
so that would be a major mistake so with the minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example there's
20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes in the 20 patterns uh sorry the 20 steps
so the reason for that would mean uh it needs to be absolutely perfect to get uh
to not get a deduction of 0.1 so it's not uncommon let's say there's 20 steps and you made let's say
15 mistakes so what would that be so we'll leave that there uh on this side and we'll
come back and we'll just calculate the score at the uh at the end so uh major mistake say you're
supposed to turn to the left when you turn to the right that would be a major mistake so obviously
we do want to try to avoid any of these major mistakes so uh after we've done our pattern
that's when we move on to the presentation side so the presentation as you can see it's from a
score of six uh this six is actually split up into three parts so we have one two three here
this one uh for a score of two is your power and speed your rhythm is also a score of two
and your expression of energy is also scored out of two as well so we'll start off with the power
and speed so with this one whether it's your blocks your kicks your strikes your punches
anything you are that you do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well
so that it's one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong
and fast to get uh high in that in that category so the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm
uh when you do start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast
all the way through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of
aspect to it as well so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also scored out
the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's
how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so say you're doing
your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is really great but you're not
shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of tell well you're not really
confident you're a little bit nervous so that's why i wanted to kind of improve on on as well so
i'll just come around to this side so with this one four color belts and black belts
actually scored a little bit differently so if you're in colorful you'll actually your average
so where where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a 1.1 so this is your average so
say you did uh you did alright you did average compared to everyone else your score for one two
and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than average in the judges eyes you might
go down to say for your power and speed you might go down to
get a 1 or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual
category you need to obviously get as high as you can if you're a black belt generally depending on
the competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average that you start from so
say your current speed was above average you might get scored a one point say let's say 1.4 for now
say your rhythm was only about average it wasn't amazing it might be just a 1.3 but let's say you
didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3 it might drop to say
let's say a 1.0 so with this one
we'll come over down to this side so with this one as i was saying it's a total of 10 so let's
see before presentation we had 1.7 1 2 3 so you had a 3.7 let's say you made 15 mistakes so with
this one obviously don't be too discouraged if you do get pretty high in your mistakes this is
with the judge
we have three judges usually at the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective so
from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may
may have made not a lot of mistakes as well so that's why we have the three judges
and we average it out as well okay so uh saying we did our 15 mistakes very small mistakes so
if they're all uh minus 0.1 it'd be 1.5
so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your accuracy score
so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 here
so we add these numbers at the uh after the judges are finished scoring so you would get for this
pattern a 6.2 which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this
number here so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns it's
not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four to five so if you get a
number between uh four and five out of ten for your pattern that's actually uh generally considered
pretty good so anything above that uh you can consider yourself pretty good uh if you're a
black belt the average would say because um we're talking here about the the higher presentation as
an average anything from five to oh two sorry five to six is actually considered uh pretty
pretty good and anything over a seven is actually considered almost world class so if you get a
seventh or any of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job
uh we just went through our poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is
a 6.0 accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get two scores
that we add up we get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was i was judge number one
i would give you a 6.2 there was another another judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more
than i did and maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a five point something
another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get the three numbers
and then we'd average that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys so make sure you enjoy
your content competitions and anytime make sure obviously you record down your numbers as well so
okay some minor errors major errors minor errors while you're watching your video again
major errors we cannot pause this time and then after the poomsae we'll be doing power and speed
coordination of rhythm and expression of energy okay okay when you're ready
i know i
we're going to lock
all right
you're interacting with it oh yeah
All right.